OK. Here was the idea. They were private investigators, detectives for hire. But they were not grizzled ex-cops in trench coats or old Humphrey Bogart characters in fedoras dragging on their unfiltered cigarettes. They were moms. Soccer moms. Telegenic, sexy soccer moms. Like some kind of MILF Charlie's Angels.
好的，想法是这样的。她们是私家侦探，受雇的侦探。但她们不是那种穿着风衣、满脸风霜的退休警察，也不是汉弗莱·鲍嘉电影里那种叼着无过滤香烟的硬汉。她们是妈妈。足球妈妈。上镜、性感的足球妈妈。就像某种熟女版的《查理的天使》。
And you could see why that would be a hit. Why people loved that. And why it was really only a matter of time before they would show up as guests on some daytime TV talk show.
你可以看出为什么这会火。为什么人们喜欢这个。为什么这只是时间问题，迟早她们会出现在某个日间电视脱口秀节目里。
On the next Dr. Phil. They look like your average moms, but they're also--
在下一期《菲尔博士》节目中。她们看起来像普通的妈妈，但她们也是——
Gun-packing, hard-hitting private investigators. You would never expect a mom in a minivan to be somebody that's on your tail.
携带枪支、雷厉风行的私家侦探。你永远不会想到开着小型货车的妈妈会是跟踪你的人。
The brains behind this whole PI Mom thing was a guy named Chris Butler. The way Chris Butler tells it, he'd been running a regular PI firm, when at some point, he hired a mom. According to Chris, this was the Eureka moment. He realized that moms have what it takes to crack cases. Patience, organization, hunches. Plus, they blend in.
这一整个“妈妈侦探”概念的幕后主脑是一个叫克里斯·巴特勒的人。据克里斯·巴特勒所说，他经营着一家普通的侦探事务所，直到有一次，他雇佣了一位妈妈。克里斯说，这就是灵感迸发的时刻。他意识到妈妈们具备破案所需的素质。耐心、组织能力、直觉。此外，她们还能融入人群。
Anyway, that was the shtick. Chris called it his secret formula, and he built a business around it.
总之，这就是他们的噱头。克里斯称之为他的秘密配方，并围绕它建立了一项业务。
--5 PM. Charmagne to run on point. That photograph in front of you is when we did recon. That's what the layout of the rooms look like.
——下午5点。让夏曼担任突击手。你们面前的那张照片是我们进行侦察时拍的。这就是房间的布局看起来的样子。
Inside this bag, we have the recording units.
在这个包里，我们有录音设备。
Chris Butler didn't want to talk to us. This is a tape of him running a sting operation on the hour-long episode of Dr. Phil that featured the PI Moms. And that was just one of several big media appearances for Chris and the Moms last year. There was also the Today show, and Fox and a People magazine article, complete with a two page photo spread of three PI Moms in dresses and heels, posed like Charlie's Angels .
克里斯·巴特勒不想跟我们说话。这是一段他在《菲尔博士》的一小时专题节目中执行诱捕行动的录音，该节目专门介绍了“妈妈侦探”。这只是克里斯和妈妈们去年几次大型媒体亮相中的一次。此外还有《今日秀》、福克斯电视台以及《人物》杂志的一篇文章，文章配有两页的照片，照片中三位妈妈侦探穿着裙子和高跟鞋，摆出《查理的天使》那样的姿势。
I was first approached by his PR agent in Beverly Hills. And his PR agent told me that they had just been on the Today show, and in People , and they were just about to be on Dr. Phil , so I should write about them.
我最初是被他位于比佛利山的公关代理人联系上的。他的公关告诉我，他们刚上了《今日秀》和《人物》杂志，马上还要上《菲尔博士》，所以我应该写写他们。
This is Pete Crooks, a writer and an editor for Diablo magazine. Diablo is one of those glossy monthly magazines that lots of places have, like Chicago magazine, or Columbus Monthly, or Memphis magazine. This particular one serves the East Bay area outside of San Francisco, including the Diablo Valley. The magazine has restaurant reviews, and local events listings, and enthusiastic profiles of celebrities from the area. Pete covers entertainment, so he is the one who got the pitch from the PI Moms public relations person, who told him that Chris Butler and the Moms had just landed a deal for a reality TV show on Lifetime.
这是皮特·克鲁克斯，《迪亚布罗》杂志的一位作家和编辑。《迪亚布罗》是那种很多地方都有的亮面月刊杂志，比如《芝加哥》杂志、《哥伦布月刊》或《孟菲斯》杂志。这份特定的杂志服务于旧金山郊外的东湾地区，包括迪亚布罗谷。杂志上有餐厅评论、本地活动列表，以及对当地名人的热情专访。皮特负责娱乐版块，所以他是从“妈妈侦探”的公关那里收到推介的人，对方告诉他克里斯·巴特勒和妈妈们刚刚签下了一档Lifetime电视台的真人秀。
I said, you know, we have to do something about this, if this is going to be the Real Housewives meets Magnum PI, and it's all filmed in our backyard with East Bay moms and an East Bay boss. And the PR specialist promised me that I could do more than interview. I could actually ride along on a case and be embedded with the PI Moms.
我说，你知道，如果这要成为《比弗利娇妻》遇上《神探亨特》，而且全部都在我们的后院拍摄，由东湾妈妈和东湾老板主演，那我们得做点什么。公关专家向我保证，我可以做的不只是采访。我甚至可以参与案件，嵌入到“妈妈侦探”的行动中去。
Which was perfect. He'd be ahead of the curve on this story that was going to be on national TV and had this strong local angle, and it was a fun story. An easy story. One day reporting, where you ride around with the Moms, photos on a stakeout or whatever, which could be great, a quick writeup. And that is the way it started.
这真是太完美了。他能在国家电视台播出这个故事之前领先一步，而且故事有很强的本地视角，又是一个有趣的故事。一个轻松的故事。一天的报道，你跟着妈妈们到处转，在监视点拍照什么的，这会很棒，可以快速写出一篇稿子。事情就是这样开始的。
But Pete ended up spending months on this simple feature story. It unfolded and unfolded, and by the end, he found himself caught up in a very strange world where he was getting mysterious messages from an anonymous informant. For a while, it was unclear who he should believe about anything. And things that were not what they seemed were even less what they seemed than he thought they were when he first discovered they were not what they seemed.
但皮特最后在这个简单的专题故事上花了几个月的时间。事情不断发展，到最后，他发现自己陷入了一个非常奇怪的世界，收到了来自匿名线人的神秘信息。有一段时间，他不知道该相信谁。事情变得越发扑朔迷离，比他最初发现它们不是表面看起来那样时还要复杂得多。
Today we take you on that same trip that he went on. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today, The Incredible Case of the PI Moms. Stay with us.
今天，我们带你踏上他所经历的旅程。从芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的主题是《妈妈侦探的惊人案件》。请继续收听。
Josh Bearman has been talking to all the available witnesses in this case, and he tells the story.
乔什·贝尔曼一直在与此案所有可用的证人交谈，他将讲述这个故事。
So one Thursday, Pete Crooks goes down to the PI Moms HQ. He introduces himself, gets some background interviews, and meets the Moms and their boss, Chris Butler, the man at the wheel of this minivan full of suburban spy gals.
所以，在一个周四，皮特·克鲁克斯去了“妈妈侦探”的总部。他介绍了自己，做了些背景采访，见到了妈妈们和她们的老板克里斯·巴特勒，这个男人正驾驶着这辆装满了郊区女间谍的小型货车。
Chris met me at the office. He was Mr. Cool, like right out of a TV show. In fact, I walked in and I saw there were framed 8 by 10 photos of, like, Colombo, and Cagney and Lacey, and Magnum PI, Charlie's Angels, all the '70s and '80s private eyes from television.
克里斯在办公室见了我是。他很有派头，就像从电视剧里走出来的一样。事实上，我走进去的时候，看到墙上挂着装裱好的8x10照片，有《神探可伦坡》、《卡格尼和蕾西》、《神探亨特》、《查理的天使》，全都是70和80年代的电视私家侦探。
Chris actually was an ex-cop, but he parted ways with official law enforcement because, as he described it on his website, his bosses, quote, "had trouble understanding his tactics and drive," which were well above the standards of routine performance.
克里斯实际上曾是一名警察，但他离开了官方执法部门，因为正如他在网站上描述的那样，他的上司“无法理解他的战术和干劲”，这些战术和干劲远超常规表现的标准。
And then was Chris, who's this kind of puffed-up sort of burly guy with a blond goatee and, like, a very tight black sort of motorcycle T-shirt, tight jeans, and very expensive leather boots. He kind of looked like a biker cowboy cop. His voice just didn't ever change octaves. He definitely had this coolest guy in the room attitude.
然后是克里斯，他是一个有点浮夸、体格魁梧的家伙，留着金色山羊胡，穿着一件非常紧身的黑色摩托车T恤，紧身牛仔裤，还有非常昂贵的皮靴。他看起来就像一个骑手牛仔警察。他的声音从不变换音调。他绝对有一种“屋子里最酷的人”的态度。
Chris sat behind his desk, flanked by his posters and two PI Moms, Charmagne Peters and Denise Antoon. Pete had seen them all on the TV segments. And then, to everyone's surprise, a client showed up.
克里斯坐在办公桌后，旁边是他的海报和两位妈妈侦探，夏曼·彼得斯和丹妮丝·安图恩。皮特在电视节目中见过她们。然后，令所有人惊讶的是，一位客户出现了。
Chris sees a a luxury car pull into the parking lot right outside his office. And this woman comes in who has retained Chris to follow her fiance around to see if he's fooling around. She comes in. Attractive woman in her early 50s. And she explains the situation, and tells me how long she's been engaged to this man, and where she met him.
克里斯看到一辆豪华轿车开进了他办公室外的停车场。这位聘请克里斯跟踪她未婚夫以查看他是否出轨的女士进来了。她进来了。一位50岁出头的迷人女性。她解释了情况，并告诉了我她和这个男人订婚了多久，以及他们在哪里认识的。
And over the past six to eight months, she's just really noticed that he's becoming more distant, and that he goes to the gym on Saturdays. And he used to go for an hour and a half to work out and come home. Now he's gone for seven, eight hours at a time. And on one of these recent trips to the gym, when he came back, she peeked inside his gym bag, and all his workout clothes were clean and neatly folded.
在过去的六到八个月里，她注意到他变得更加疏远，而且他周六都会去健身房。他过去工作一个半小时就会回家。现在他每次一去就是七八个小时。最近有一次去健身房时，他回来后，她偷看了他的健身包，发现他所有的健身服都是干净且叠得整整齐齐的。
She was composed, and then she starts crying and saying that she just needs to know. If there's some funny business going on, she needs to know now. Because this is a big point in their relationship
她表现得很镇定，然后开始哭泣，说她只是需要知道真相。如果真的有出轨的事发生，她现在必须知道。因为这是他们关系的一个重要关头。
It's like the opening scene of practically every detective film ever made. Nice-looking lady walks into the PI's office with tears in her eyes. Except this one has a PI Moms twist.
这就像几乎每一部侦探电影的开场戏。漂亮的女士带着泪水走进侦探办公室。只是这个案子多了个“妈妈侦探”的转折。
When the client starts to cry, one of the PI Moms jumped up with a box of tissues, and the other one said, "Do you need a hug?" And they had this sort of bonding moment, the two PI Moms and the crying client.
当客户开始哭泣时，一位妈妈侦探跳起来拿了一盒纸巾，另一位说：“你需要一个拥抱吗？”她们有了这种联结时刻，两个妈妈侦探和哭泣的客户。
The client suggested the following Saturday for the stakeout. Charmagne and Denise were ready with their surveillance minivan, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] recording devices, and the subject's photo and address. Pete sat in the back, taking notes.
客户提议在接下来的周六进行监视。夏曼和丹妮丝准备好了她们的监视货车、录音设备，以及目标的照片和地址。皮特坐在后面做笔记。
Sure enough, the fiance quickly appeared. They followed him to a 24 Hour Fitness, where Denise and Charmagne videotaped him going in.
果然，未婚夫很快出现了。他们跟着他来到了一家24小时健身房，丹妮丝和夏曼拍下了他进去的过程。
Within ten minutes, he came out of that same front door of the gym, dressed up in this sort of Tommy Bahamas leisure wear. Like khaki slacks and dress shoes and a short-sleeved sort of dressy shirt. And Charmagne said, oh, don't we look pretty?
十分钟内，他从健身房的同一个前门出来了，穿着那种汤米巴哈马休闲装。比如卡其色休闲裤、正装鞋和短袖花衬衫。夏曼说，哦，我们看起来不是很漂亮吗？
And that was just the start of it. They tailed the fiance to a gated community where a young, attractive brunette appeared. She was half the client's age, buffed, glossed, and tattooed up her entire right arm. The couple got in the car and the Moms followed.
而这仅仅是个开始。他们尾随未婚夫到一个门禁社区，那里出现了一位年轻迷人的黑发女郎。她只有客户年龄的一半，身材健美，光彩照人，整条右臂上都有纹身。这对男女上了车，妈妈们紧随其后。
Pete realized they were headed for Napa. The cheaters would spend the day wine-tasting. Classy, Pete thought.
皮特意识到他们正前往纳帕。通奸者要花一天时间去品酒。皮特心想，真有格调。
But Pete started noticing a few things. He was no pro at clandestine reconnaissance, but he did wonder at times about the PI Moms' strange technique.
但皮特开始注意到一些事情。他不是秘密侦察方面的专家，但他有时确实对妈妈侦探奇怪的技术感到疑惑。
We'd been following him from his house to the gym, from the gym to the gated community, and from the gated community to the freeway, exactly one car length in the same minivan behind this guy.
我们从他家一直跟着他到健身房，从健身房到门禁社区，再从门禁社区到高速公路，一直保持着刚好一个车距，在同一辆小型货车里跟在这个家伙后面。
When the fiance turned, they turned. When he made a mistake and had to pull a sudden illegal U-turn, the Moms pulled the exact same maneuver. At one point, the couple stopped at Starbucks. And if you'll just visualize this for a moment, the mommy minivan was right behind them, subject car and tail car, crawling towards iced mochas, alone in a half-empty parking lot.
当未婚夫转弯时，他们也转弯。当他犯错不得不突然非法掉头时，妈妈们做了完全一样的动作。有一次，这对男女在星巴克停了下来。如果你能想象一下：妈妈们的小型货车就在他们后面，目标车在前，跟踪车在后，慢慢地朝冰摩卡开去，在一个半空的停车场里，显得格外显眼。
And I started to ask, you know, don't you have to hang back a little bit? And Charmagne and Denise said, no, no. You know, he's in his own little world there, on his date. He doesn't even realize we're here.
我开始问，你知道，你们不需要稍微保持一点距离吗？夏曼和丹妮丝说，不，不。你知道，他在他自己的小世界里约会呢。他甚至没有意识到我们在场。
Did you just think that they were incompetent at doing this kind of thing? Or did you think that they in fact knew exactly what they were doing? When they reassured you, did you say, oh, well, they've done this before?
你当时是觉得她们做这种事很无能吗？还是你觉得她们实际上非常清楚自己在做什么？当她们安抚你时，你说，噢，好吧，她们以前也做过这些？
I have to admit, I went along with it and thought, they've been doing this five days a week, and I've never gone on a ride along with an investigator before. And I just continued to record notes and go along with it.
我不得不承认，我顺着她们的意思，心想，她们每周五天都在做这个，而且我以前从未跟着侦探一起行动过。所以我继续记录笔记，跟着她们。
Pete and the Moms followed the fiance and the mistress for hours. They watched them shop for discount jewelry and then move onto a Napa restaurant called the Rutherford Grill.
皮特和妈妈们尾随未婚夫和情妇好几个小时。他们看着他们买折扣珠宝，然后转到一家叫卢瑟福烧烤的纳帕餐厅。
The subject and the mystery date parked their car. We parked right behind them. They walk right in front of our van. Denise is running a video camera through the front window of the van, and they stop right in front of the van to kiss. I mean, five feet in front of us.
目标和神秘约会对象停好了车。我们紧跟在他们后面停车。他们就在我们的货车前走过。丹妮丝正透过货车前窗用摄像机拍摄，他们停在货车前亲吻。我的意思是，就在我们面前五英尺的地方。
So Denise has a camera trained at them.
所以丹妮丝有对着他们的摄像机。
Point blank, yeah. A big, bulky camera, too. Not some sort of hidden camera.
近距离拍摄，是的。也是一个又大又笨重的摄像机。不是那种隐藏式摄像机。
It was a lovely day-- the kind of day that brings people out to Napa-- and the restaurant was packed. Turned out the only place for the PI Moms to sit was a communal table, where, as it happened, the fiance was already seated, hoping to feed his mistress French fries.
那天天气很好——那种把人们吸引到纳帕的天气——餐厅里挤满了人。结果“妈妈侦探”唯一能坐的地方是一张共享餐桌，碰巧的是，未婚夫已经坐在那里，希望能喂他的情妇吃炸薯条。
And so the investigators and Pete wound up essentially having lunch with their targets. Again, Pete wondered if their cover could be blown by being that close. So close that Pete had to say hello to the mistress as they sat down, and then listen to their lunchtime chatter.
于是侦探们和皮特基本上和他们的目标一起吃了午餐。皮特再次怀疑，离得这么近会不会暴露。离得太近了，以至于皮特坐下时不得不跟那个情妇打招呼，然后听他们的午餐闲谈。
Their conversation was lurid. The fellow kept saying, boy, you look hot today. She says, yeah, I'm hot. I'm sweating. And he says, I'd like to lick that sweat off of you. And she goes, oh, yeah, I'd like that. But like, just without any passion whatsoever.
他们的对话很低俗。那个男人一直在说，天哪，你今天看起来很辣。她说，是啊，我很热。我在流汗。他说，我想舔掉你身上的汗水。她说，哦，是的，我喜欢那样。但听起来完全没有激情。
And then she says, I was thinking about going horseback riding tomorrow. And he goes, yeah, where do you go horseback riding? And she says, oh, I've got some friend who has a stables out in Bullinger Canyon. And he says, is that near where we got that hotel room that night? That was a wild night.
然后她说，我考虑明天去骑马。他说，是啊，你去哪里骑马？她说，哦，我有朋友在布林格峡谷有马厩。他说，那离我们那天开那个旅馆房间的地方近吗？那真是一个狂野的夜晚。
So he always kind of turns the conversation back to sex talk, and she kind of goes off talking about horseback riding or whatever. It was very bizarre, and it just sounded like, if this is what infidelity is-- there's just no passion or substance to it whatsoever. And the client back in the East Bay is better off without this guy.
所以他总是把话题转回性爱话题，她就聊骑马什么的。这非常离奇，听起来就像，如果这就是不忠——它根本没有任何激情或实质内容。东湾的那位客户离开这个家伙会更好。
Meanwhile, Denise and Charmagne were ordering burgers and ribs, and not really paying attention to the conversation. And we all sort of scarfed down burgers and ribs, and it was just like a very casual lunch. And nobody seemed to be concerned at the awkward situation except myself.
与此同时，丹妮丝和夏曼正在点汉堡和排骨，并没有太注意谈话。我们大家都狼吞虎咽地吃了汉堡和排骨，这就像一顿非常随意的午餐。除了我之外，似乎没有人对这种尴尬的情况感到担心。
I know. This sounds fake. And that's because it is fake-- fakety fake, totally fake. And the only person who doesn't know it's fake, at this point, is Pete. Everything else-- the mistress, the crying client, the hot, hot horse-ridey sex talk, the affair itself, has been meticulously choreographed by Chris Butler.
我知道。这听起来很假。那是因为它确实是假的——虚假、彻底的虚假。而此时唯一不知道这是假的人就是皮特。其他一切——情妇、哭泣的客户、火辣辣的骑马性爱谈话、婚外情本身，都是由克里斯·巴特勒精心编排的。
You know, one thing I will say-- Chris was very, very good at reading people. He knew how to read people, and he knew how to push the right buttons. He was very good at it.
你知道，有一点我必须说——克里斯非常非常擅长解读他人。他懂得如何解读人，也知道如何按对按钮。他非常擅长这一点。
This is Sharon Roof. She's the client-- the woman with a cheating fiance. While most of the people playing roles in the fake case were actors or friends of Chris Butler, Sharon is interesting because she had actually hired Chris Butler and the PI Moms months earlier, to follow her real cheating fiancee, and they caught him. She'd been impressed by Chris, and thought he was a nice guy. He'd gotten the truth for her, after all.
这是莎伦·鲁夫。她是那位客户——那位有出轨未婚夫的女性。虽然大多数在虚假案件中扮演角色的都是演员或克里斯·巴特勒的朋友，但莎伦很有意思，因为她几个月前确实聘请过克里斯·巴特勒和“妈妈侦探”去跟踪她真正的出轨未婚夫，他们抓到了他。她对克里斯印象深刻，认为他是个好人。毕竟，他帮她查出了真相。
And then he convinced her to come and work for him. Sharon agreed, doing mostly office management, until one day, Chris took Sharon to lunch and told her about this big upcoming feature in Diablo magazine.
然后他劝她来为他工作。莎伦同意了，主要做办公室管理，直到有一天，克里斯带莎伦去吃午饭，并告诉她关于《迪亚布罗》杂志即将到来的大专题报道的事。
And he asks me, he goes, are you comfortable? I'd like to use your story.
他问我，他说，你感觉如何？我想用你的故事。
By "use her story," Chris meant he wanted to reenact her case. Sharon was skeptical at first, but eventually she agreed.
所谓的“用她的故事”，是指克里斯想重演她的案件。莎伦起初表示怀疑，但最终她同意了。
So then we sat down, you know, all of us, in the conference room, going over, OK, so this is what's going to happen. And then he starts changing the story. And I pulled him aside. I said, Chris, why are you changing the story? And he said, well, it's not exciting enough. Your story isn't exciting enough, and I want to just make it more exciting.
于是我们坐在一起，你知道，我们所有人，在会议室里，过了一遍：好的，那么接下来会发生什么。然后他开始修改故事。我把他拉到一边。我说，克里斯，你为什么要修改故事？他说，嗯，不够刺激。你的故事不够刺激，我想让它更刺激一点。
So then everything started changing. So it's like, OK. Now we're play acting. And I really didn't feel comfortable with it. But then he said, you know, Sharon, think about all the women that you'd be helping. All these women that their husbands, their boyfriends cheat on them, and you know, blah, blah, blah. So I did. I went along with it.
于是所有事情都开始改变了。所以就像是，好的。现在我们在演戏。我真的觉得不舒服。但他又说，你知道，莎伦，想想你将要帮助的所有女性。所有那些丈夫、男朋友背叛她们的女性，你知道，等等等等。所以我照做了。我顺从了。
But for the drama to work, Chris wanted Sharon to nail the emotional heart of the performance.
但为了让戏剧效果起作用，克里斯希望莎伦能把握住表演的情感核心。
Chris told me-- he said, Sharon, he goes, just go back in time to when you came to me those couple months ago, when Michael was cheating on you. And that's where your head's at when you come in and talk to Peter. So that's exactly where my head was at. So those tears were real. Everything was real. It was like I was reliving the same conversation I had with Chris when I came to first meet him.
克里斯告诉我——他说，莎伦，他说，回到几个月前你来找我的时候，当迈克尔背叛你的时候。当你进来和皮特谈话时，这就是你的心境。所以我当时的心境就是这样。所以那些眼泪是真的。一切都是真实的。就像我重温了第一次来见他时和克里斯的谈话。
And so there was Pete. An audience of one for Chris Butler's production, which only got more intricate as the day wore on, with an expanding cast of characters and plot-enhancing cameos. Such as this moment, when Pete and the Moms were approached by a car.
于是皮特就在那里。克里斯·巴特勒这场制作的唯一观众，随着一天的推移，这场制作变得更加错综复杂，有着不断扩大的角色阵容和增强情节的客串。比如这个时刻，皮特和妈妈们被一辆车拦住了。
This souped-up black, late model Mustang zips in and parks next to us, and this married couple gets out. A second team of investigators.
这辆经过改装的黑色新款野马车飞驰而来，停在我们旁边，这对已婚夫妇下车了。第二组调查员。
Here is one of those investigators, Carl Marino, an actor and model from San Francisco.
这是其中一位调查员，卡尔·马里诺，来自旧金山的演员兼模特。
We drove over, pulled up with a flourish in front of them, with a nice, shiny black Mustang. Of course we got out all Hollywood style with the sunglasses on, and dressed to the T.
我们开车过来，带着漂亮闪亮的黑色野马，盛装出现在他们面前。当然，我们像好莱坞明星一样戴着墨镜，穿着打扮得无可挑剔地下了车。
Carl and his wife that day were playing backup investigators. A good-looking rapid strike force. They went in, sat next to the couple, shared some wine, and texted reports back to Pete and the Moms about how friendly everyone was getting.
卡尔和他那天扮演的妻子是后备调查员。一支帅气的快速打击部队。他们走进去，坐在那对夫妇旁边，分享了一些葡萄酒，并给皮特和妈妈们发去短信，报告说每个人都相处得多么融洽。
The first text said, "Made contact with subject." The second text said, "We are talking to them and taking pics together." The third text said, "They are drunk," and the fourth text said, "They just invited us back to their hotel." So within half an hour, 45 minutes of wine tasting with strangers, they've invited them to come swing at a hotel.
第一条短信说：“与目标取得联系。”第二条短信说：“我们正在和他们交谈，一起拍照。”第三条短信说：“他们喝醉了”，第四条短信说：“他们刚刚邀请我们去他们的酒店。”所以，在和陌生人品酒半小时到45分钟内，他们就已经被邀请去酒店玩换妻游戏了。
So that escalated pretty fast, sounds like.
听起来升级得很快。
Yeah.
是的。
Again, here's Carl.
再次介绍一下，这是卡尔。
And that was something that wasn't planned out. That was something Chris kind of threw in there. And he was telling me what to text them.
那是没有计划的。那是克里斯临时加进去的。而且他在告诉我该给他们发什么短信。
Oh, that a snap decision, right there? Chris is like, let's just change this up a little bit?
噢，那是一个即兴决定，对吧？克里斯就像是说，我们要稍微改变一下？
Yeah, take up to another level.
是的，把它提高到一个新的水平。
The next level turned out to be a Holiday Inn Express parking lot. Once everyone was there-- the cheating couple, the other couple, the minivan with the PI Moms-- Pete found out that Chris was en route with the last person you'd want there. The client, Sharon. Here's Pete again.
下一个水平原来是假日酒店快捷酒店的停车场。当每个人都到达那里后——出轨的那对、另一对夫妇、带着“妈妈侦探”的小型货车——皮特发现克里斯正带着最不想让其出现的人赶往纳帕。那就是客户莎伦。这是皮特。
She now wants to see this with her own eyes, and so he is driving up to Napa with the client. And at this point, I said, Charmagne, that's a terrible idea.
她现在想亲眼见证这一切，所以他正带着客户开车前往纳帕。这时我说，夏曼，这是个糟糕的主意。
At one point, there was concern that Peter didn't believe it.
有一次，人们担心皮特不相信这一点。
Again, this is the client, Sharon Roof.
再次声明，这是客户莎伦·鲁夫。
So there was talk in the car that OK, we've got to make this good, because Peter is very suspicious. Some of this stuff just doesn't sound right to him. So we have to be very convincing.
所以车里有讨论说好的，我们必须做好，因为皮特非常怀疑。有些事情听起来对他来说不太对劲。所以我们必须非常有说服力。
Sharon was to have a big final scene, where she would look in the trunk of the car, see the fake presents her fake fiance had bought for his fake mistress, and then, right there in the parking lot, Sharon would have a real meltdown.
莎伦要表演一场盛大的终场戏，她会翻开汽车后备箱，看到她假未婚夫买给假情妇的假礼物，然后就在停车场里，莎伦会真的崩溃。
And then I just closed my eyes and I just thought about Michael. And it made it that much easier for me to get all upset.
然后我闭上眼睛，想到了迈克尔。这让我更容易变得心烦意乱。
You just went into the zone.
你只是进入了那种状态。
I did. I did. And then, you know--
是的，是的。然后，你知道——
The client jumps out of the Chrysler.
客户从克莱斯勒车里跳了出来。
I got out of the car. The car barely was in park and I ran out.
我下了车。车还没停稳，我就跑了出去。
Runs over to her car, opens the trunk, looks in the gift bag to see what kind of jewelry her fiance had bought his mistress, and then she just collapses into a heap of tears in the trunk of her car.
跑到她的车旁，打开后备箱，看看未婚夫给情妇买了什么样的珠宝，然后她就瘫倒在后备箱里，哭成了一团。
She actually falls into the trunk of the car?
她真的倒进了车后备箱里？
Just crying. Just her upper body and her head just sort of disappear into the trunk of the car in this exhausted heap of humiliation. It was very awkward.
只是哭。她的上半身和头部消失在车后备箱里，成了一团精疲力竭的羞耻堆。非常尴尬。
Actually, somebody told me later that Peter was so upset about me that he couldn't watch. And I guess he went to go get a coffee at a Starbucks or something. So I don't even know if he saw any of my performance.
事实上，后来有人告诉我，皮特对我的表现感到非常不安，以至于他看不下去了。我猜他去星巴克买咖啡什么的了。所以我甚至不知道他是否看到了我的表演。
You were just doing it for yourself. Like, the audience wasn't even there.
你只是为了自己而做。就像观众根本不在那里一样。
Yeah, I mean, I didn't notice who was around to be honest. But then somebody told me that Peter was here, and then I felt bad that Peter was upset. Because you think a reporter is immune to this, because you do this all day long. You see all this stuff that you're, you know, kind of like a doctor when you operate. You're used to it. But Peter had a heart.
是的，我的意思是，老实说我没注意到周围有谁。但后来有人告诉我皮特在那儿，然后我因为皮特感到不安而觉得不好受。因为你会认为记者对此有免疫力，因为你整天都在做这个。你看到所有这些事情，你知道，就像医生在手术时一样。你习惯了。但皮特有一颗心。
Here's Pete again.
这是皮特。
My story was to watch the PI Moms investigate, and not to dwell on this client's sadness or humiliation. And I had been craving a Starbucks for the past five, six hours, since I had seen the cheating couple go in.  So I went over to the Starbucks and got myself a coffee.
我的故事是观看“妈妈侦探”进行调查，而不是沉浸在这个客户的悲伤或羞辱中。而且在过去的五六个小时里，我一直渴望喝杯星巴克，自从我看到出轨的那对走进去之后。所以我去了星巴克，给自己买了一杯咖啡。
So while she's kind of regaining her composure, you just went and got, like, a Frappuccino or something?
所以当她在恢复镇定时，你只是去买了杯星冰乐什么的？
Yeah, I got a latte.
是的，我买了一杯拿铁。
By the time it was done, the stakeout had lasted eight hours. And despite all the red flags, Pete still believed it all. Remember, these people had appeared in all kinds of news stories already. They'd been on the Today show. Pete presumed they'd been vetted and fact-checked. And there was going to be a whole reality show about the Moms. It was just about to start filming.
到结束时，监视行动已经持续了八个小时。尽管有所有的危险信号，皮特仍然相信这一切。记住，这些人之前已经出现在各种新闻报道中了。她们上过《今日秀》。皮特推测她们已经经过审查和事实核实。而且会有一整个关于妈妈们的真人秀。拍摄马上就要开始了。
So Pete went home that day thinking, this is awesome. The desperate client. The tender-yet-tough PI Moms. The sweat-licking. And he started writing up his story. Until--
所以皮特那天回家时心想，这太棒了。绝望的客户。温柔又强硬的“妈妈侦探”。舔汗水。他开始写他的故事。直到——
So this first email was sent on Monday, January 3, 2011 at 12:21 PM, with the subject line "Peter Crooks, Important, PI Moms." "Hi. I am writing this as a courtesy to you. It would be a mistake to publish the article on the PI Moms and Chris Butler that you came and did a story on a few months ago. Chris totally played you. The case that you sat in on was totally scripted."
所以第一封电子邮件是在2011年1月3日，星期一，下午12:21发送的，主题是“皮特·克鲁克斯，重要，妈妈侦探”。“嗨。我写这封信是出于礼貌。发表你几个月前去做的关于‘妈妈侦探’和克里斯·巴特勒的文章是个错误。克里斯完全在戏弄你。你参与的那个案件完全是脚本化的。”
So this is an anonymous message.
所以这是一条匿名信息。
Well, it was a message from somebody named Rutherford with an email account that you could easily make-- you know, it seemed to me that this person's name was not Rutherford. It was somebody who had made up a new, Yahoo or Gmail account to contact me anonymously.
嗯，这是一个来自一个叫卢瑟福的人的信息，用了一个你很容易就能注册的电子邮箱——你知道，在我看来这个人的名字不是卢瑟福。这是一个为了匿名联系我而编造了一个新雅虎或Gmail账户的人。
Pete's editors assumed the email was phony, written by someone with an axe to grind against Chris Butler. It seemed farfetched that the entire case was an intricate conspiracy and all those people were actors.
皮特的编辑认为这封电子邮件是假的，是一个对克里斯·巴特勒怀恨在心的人写的。整个案件是一场复杂的阴谋，所有那些人都是演员，这听起来太离谱了。
And yet this Rutherford person knew so much detail that Pete had to take it seriously. He called one of the PI Moms, and she swore it was real. Pete was still unsure, so he called Chris and confronted him directly.
然而，这个“卢瑟福”知道的细节太多了，皮特必须认真对待。他给其中一位妈妈侦探打了电话，她发誓那是真的。皮特仍然不确定，于是他给克里斯打了电话，直接质问他。
And he just-- he screamed, "What! That is BULLCRAP!" And honestly, I could-- I think in text sometimes, and I could see the all caps when he said "bullcrap."
然后他只是——他尖叫道：“什么！那是胡扯！”老实说，我可以——我有时会用文字思考，当他说“胡扯”时，我能看到全大写字母。
Chris promised Pete proof. He could show him it was real. But he never did. Instead, he started dodging Pete's calls.
克里斯答应给皮特证据。他可以向他证明那是真的。但他从未这样做。相反，他开始躲避皮特的电话。
Meanwhile, Pete and Rutherford kept emailing, with Rutherford feeding Pete information on Chris Butler, and Pete staying up late, trying to track people down on Facebook and piece it all together.
与此同时，皮特和“卢瑟福”保持着邮件往来，“卢瑟福”向皮特提供关于克里斯·巴特勒的信息，皮特熬夜，试图在Facebook上追踪这些人并拼凑出真相。
About 3 o'clock in the morning, Rutherford sends me one that we've always called in Diablo ever since then the "smoking gun email." And it was the itinerary of our Napa adventure.
大约凌晨3点，“卢瑟福”发给我一封我们从那时起在《迪亚布罗》杂志就一直称为“冒烟的枪电子邮件”。那是我们纳帕冒险的行程单。
Suddenly Pete was looking at a timeline of his entire day with the PI Moms-- a detailed schedule sent to everyone who was there.
皮特突然看到了他和“妈妈侦探”一整天的时间表——发给所有在场人员的详细日程。
It had the street addresses of the gym, of the Napa outlet store, the Rutherford Grill, of the winery, and of the Holiday Inn Express. In addition to that, it had a Google Earth photo showing an overhead view of the Holiday Inn Express with notes on it, saying, here's where the luxury car should park. Here's where the mystery date and the fiance will walk into the Holiday Inn Express. They'll walk--
上面有健身房、纳帕奥特莱斯店、卢瑟福烧烤店、酒厂和假日酒店快捷酒店的街道地址。此外，它还有一张谷歌地球照片，显示了假日酒店快捷酒店的俯视图，上面有注释，写着：豪华轿车应该停在这里。神秘约会对象和未婚夫会走进假日酒店快捷酒店。他们会走——
Now Pete was certain. He'd been a mark. As it happens, Pete's a big fan of film noir. He knows all the classics backwards and forwards. And he noted that this one didn't just start like all the good noirs, with the dame crying in the PI's office. Pete had arrived at the inevitable turn where the protagonist falls down the rabbit hole of hidden forces and mysterious motivations, where you don't know who's in on the con and who isn't.
现在皮特确定了。他被当成了猎物。碰巧皮特是黑色电影的忠实粉丝。他把所有经典作品都背得滚瓜烂熟。他注意到这不仅仅像所有好的黑色电影一样，从侦探办公室里的女人哭泣开始。皮特已经到达了不可避免的转折点，主角掉进了隐藏力量和神秘动机的兔子洞，你不知道谁是骗局的参与者，谁不是。
Why would anyone go to such lengths to fool Diablo magazine? What was Chris up to? And who was this anonymous source tipping him off?
为什么有人会费尽心思去愚弄《迪亚布罗》杂志？克里斯在打什么主意？这个向他告密的匿名线人又是谁？
I tried to think of everything that could happen, would go wrong or could go wrong. And at one point, I was just like, I have to take a chance.
我试图考虑所有可能发生的事情，会出错或可能出错的事情。有一瞬间，我心想，我必须冒险一试。
This is Rutherford. If his voice is familiar, it's because you've heard him before. The guy sending Pete those emails was Carl Marino, the backup investigator. You know, handsome guy. Black Mustang, sunglasses, dressed to the T, supposedly entertaining a foursome with the cheating couple? That guy.
这就是“卢瑟福”。如果他的声音很熟悉，那是因为你以前听过。给皮特发那些邮件的人就是后备调查员卡尔·马里诺。你知道，帅气的家伙。黑色野马，墨镜，穿着打扮得无可挑剔，假装和出轨的那对夫妇玩四人游戏？就是那个人。
Carl had met Chris Butler a couple years earlier, not long after he moved to San Francisco. Carl had answered an ad on Craigslist looking for someone with law enforcement and acting experience. Perfect, Carl thought. He was a former sheriff's deputy, and had started doing local acting work.
卡尔在几年前，搬到旧金山不久后遇到了克里斯·巴特勒。卡尔回应了Craiglist上的一则广告，寻找有执法和表演经验的人。卡尔心想，太完美了。他曾是一名副警长，并开始做本地的表演工作。
The two of them, both former cops, hit it off right away. Eventually Carl became a central part of Butler's team. He was given the title "Director of Operations." And he realized that this wasn't the usual PI firm. There were real cases, like cheating spouses. There were performances staged for the media, like the thing with Pete. And then there were all kinds of weird things somewhere in between.
他们两个，都是前警察，一拍即合。最终卡尔成了巴特勒团队的核心成员。他被赋予了“行动总监”的职位。他意识到这并不是普通的侦探事务所。确实有真正的案子，比如出轨配偶。有为媒体精心策划的表演，比如和皮特的那次。还有各种介于两者之间的怪事。
Because that's how Chris operated. Even when people came in with actual problems, he would spin some fabrication around them, layering real over fake over real. He made stuff up when there was no reason to make anything up, And that's how simple situations often escalated.
因为这就是克里斯的运作方式。即使人们带着真实的问题来找他，他也会编造一些谎言围绕着他们，将真实层层叠加在虚假之上。他在没有理由造假的时候也会造假，这就是为什么简单的情况往往会升级。
One of the best examples of this is the case of the Candyman. Again, here's Carl.
其中最好的例子就是糖果人案。再次介绍一下，这是卡尔。
The mother came in with basically a blue ecstasy pill and said, I think my son's selling drugs. I found this.
母亲带着一颗蓝色摇头丸进来说，我觉得我儿子在卖毒品。我发现了这个。
This began as a real case when a woman came to Chris Butler with suspicions that her 19 year old son was selling drugs at college. Exhibit A was a pill that his mom found in his room. Exhibit B might have been that his friends called him the Candyman. Anyhow, it could have been a simple job. Follow the kid, videotape him selling X to college students, and the mom will have her proof. But that wasn't enough for Chris.
这始于一个真实的案件，当一名妇女带着怀疑来到克里斯·巴特勒身边，认为她19岁的儿子在大学卖毒品。证据A是她在儿子房间里发现的一颗药丸。证据B可能是他的朋友叫他“糖果人”。无论如何，这本可以是一个简单的工作。跟踪那个孩子，拍下他向大学生卖摇头丸的视频，妈妈就会有证据。但这对于克里斯来说不够。
And Chris basically said, well, we can not only do that, but how about not only do we find out if he's selling drugs, but we set him up in a way where he'll never want to do it again?
克里斯基本上说，嗯，我们不仅可以做到这一点，而且如果我们不仅查出他是否在卖毒品，还设计让他再也不敢做这件事，怎么样？
Chris's plan was to have the kid arrested-- or rather, fake arrested-- by Chris and his pals, who would then threaten him with jail time. You know, scare him straight. Incredibly his mom, the client, thought this was a great idea. So Chris planned an elaborate operation over several weeks, starting with phase one-- initial contact.
克里斯的计划是让这个孩子被捕——或者更确切地说，是假装被捕——由克里斯和他的伙伴们执行，然后威胁他会坐牢。你知道，吓唬他走正道。令人难以置信的是，他的母亲，也就是客户，认为这是个好主意。于是克里斯在几周内策划了一个精心设计的行动，从第一阶段开始——初步接触。
He sent these two female decoys to the supermarket. Called the mother. Told the mother, send your son to the supermarket to buy chicken or whatever.
他派了这两个女性诱饵去超市。给母亲打了电话。告诉母亲，让你儿子去超市买鸡肉什么的。
By decoys, Carl means young, attractive women Chris would hire through Craigslist to play temptresses. The story cooked up by Chris was that these two girls would meet the kid in the grocery store near the chicken, where they would flirt with him by asking for his expertise about the chicken, and then propose a date with both of them.
所谓的诱饵，卡尔是指年轻、迷人的女性，克里斯会通过Craiglist雇佣她们来扮演诱惑者。克里斯编造的故事是，这两个女孩会在离鸡肉柜台很近的杂货店遇见那个孩子，她们会通过询问他对鸡肉的专业知识来挑逗他，然后提议和她们俩约会。
Together.
一起。
Yeah. Both of them would go out on a date with him together, and I believe they went bowling or something like that. And during the course of this date, they would tell him that there's a party coming up soon that they want him to come to. They would insinuate that they like to hook up together, and how much they like this guy. And they would make out with the guy and stuff, too. These decoys, Chris would find decoys that had no problem doing that.
是的。她们俩会和他一起去约会，我相信他们去保龄球馆什么的了。在约会过程中，她们会告诉他很快会有一个聚会，想让他参加。她们会暗示她们喜欢一起调情，以及她们有多喜欢这个家伙。她们还会和那个家伙亲热什么的。这些诱饵，克里斯会找到毫无顾虑这样做的人。
Wow. And was it Chris's idea to like, you know, let's make this a threeway, that'll be more exciting?
哇。而且这是克里斯的主意吗，比如，让我们玩个3P，那样会更刺激？
Always. He would throw that in all the time.
总是这样。他总是会随口提出来。
Chris Butler was never the type to worry about gilding the lily. He had his decoys invite this kid to a party hosted by a third girl, a friend of theirs, who, of course, was a lingerie model. They intimated that this party would be so fun, they'd all wind up in bed together. It was a natural progression-- chicken, bowling, group sex at a party with lingerie models. Phase two, a Butler-style twist on the classic honey trap, was nearly complete.
克里斯·巴特勒从来不是那种担心画蛇添足的人。他让他的诱饵邀请这个孩子去参加第三个女孩举办的聚会，那个女孩当然是内衣模特。她们暗示这个聚会会非常有趣，他们最终都会睡在一起。这是一个自然的演变——鸡肉、保龄球、在聚会上和内衣模特群交。第二阶段，对经典的蜂蜜陷阱的巴特勒式改编，已经快完成了。
And with the hook baited, the girls yanked the line. The party is off, they told the kid. It was going to be an ecstasy party, and their dealer flew the coop. Such a bummer, right? No ecstasy, so no party, I guess.
诱饵下好了，女孩们拉紧了鱼线。聚会取消了，她们告诉那个孩子。这将是一个摇头丸派对，他们的毒贩跑路了。太倒霉了，对吧？没有摇头丸，所以我想聚会开不成了。
He's like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, hang on, hang on. Don't worry about it. I can get this stuff. Really? Can you? Great. Thank you.
他说，等等，等等，等等，等一下。别担心。我可以搞到这些东西。真的？你能吗？太棒了。谢谢。
I mean, they were talking to the Candyman, after all. And so, just as planned, the kid walked right into Chris's trap, arriving at phase three.
我的意思是，毕竟他们在跟“糖果人”说话。所以，正如计划的那样，那个孩子直接掉进了克里斯的陷阱，进入了第三阶段。
We set it up in the parking lot of the Narcotics Task Force office.
我们把它设置在禁毒特遣部队办公室的停车场里。
This is a key detail. Carl is referring to the Contra Costa County Narcotics Enforcement Task Force, also called CNET. CNET was the top drug enforcement agency in the county, and the guy who ran it was Norm Wielsch.
这是一个关键细节。卡尔指的是康特拉科斯塔县禁毒特遣部队，也称为CNET。CNET是该县最高的缉毒机构，负责人是诺姆·威尔施。
Chris Butler was friends with a lot of cops, but Norm was the biggest. They'd actually been in the same department years earlier. And now Norm and Chris started collaborating on Chris's operations. It was a strange extracurricular activity for Norm, since Chris's operational whimsies were often illegal, like the elaborate fake bust that was about to happen in the parking lot of Norm's police agency.
克里斯·巴特勒和许多警察是朋友，但诺姆是最大的一个。他们几年前实际上在同一个部门工作过。现在诺姆和克里斯开始合作克里斯的行动。这对诺姆来说是一种奇怪的课外活动，因为克里斯的操作奇思妙想往往是非法的，比如即将在警察机构停车场发生的精心策划的假抓捕。
Chris actually had one of the other investigators on the radio with a script. So when he called dispatch, she was going to be dispatch. Because he was going to be running the license plate numbers, running the kid's name. And she would be calling back like it was a police dispatch over the radio. So it looked very authentic.
克里斯实际上让其中一位调查员戴着无线电拿着脚本。所以当他打电话给调度中心时，她会担任调度员。因为他要查询车牌号，查询孩子的名字。然后她会像通过无线电的警察调度一样回电。所以看起来非常真实。
Chris also had the hummer with the strobe lights on it, the flashing strobe lights. And Norm was going to come driving up in that with the strobe lights going so it looked like a police vehicle pulling up.
克里斯还有那辆带频闪灯的悍马，闪烁的频闪灯。诺姆会开着那辆车过来，闪着频闪灯，所以看起来就像警车在靠边停车。
So Norm, A real police officer, is going to be driving in a fake police vehicle, but in the real parking lot of the police headquarters.
所以诺姆，一名真正的警察，将驾驶一辆假警车，但在警察总部的真实停车场里。
Yes.
是的。
OK. Just to keep it all straight.
好的。只是为了理清思路。
Remember, this kid was supposed to be a drug dealer. They didn't need to do any of this. They could've just followed him and filmed him. Instead, they now have a real kid selling real drugs to amateur actresses hired off Craigslist for real cash. Then they all get busted by Chris and his buddies pretending to be cops, alongside Norm, a real cop, who's driving Chris's fake police car. Again, here's Carl.
记住，这个孩子本应是一个毒贩。他们根本不需要做这些。他们本可以只是跟着他并拍下他。相反，他们现在让一个真正的孩子向从Craiglist雇来的业余女演员卖毒品。然后他们都被克里斯和他的伙伴们假扮的警察逮捕了，还有诺姆，一个真正的警察，驾驶着克里斯的假警车。再次介绍一下，这是卡尔。
And my job was to run around the front of the car, hold this kid at gunpoint. The other guy was going to go to the other side of the car. Chris was going to come running out of the bushes with the guns drawn.
我的工作是跑过车前，用枪指着这个孩子。另一个人会去车的另一边。克里斯会带着枪从灌木丛中跑出来。
And now, the guns are not loaded, presumably.
现在，这些枪大概没装子弹吧。
No. The guns were not loaded. Except for Norm, Norm had his real gun, but he didn't draw it. It was just in case something bad happened, obviously, in case this kid did have a gun or something. But that's what Norm was there for.
不。枪里没有子弹。除了诺姆，诺姆有他真正的枪，但他没有拔出来。那只是以防万一发生了什么坏事，显然，以防这个孩子真的有枪什么的。但这正是诺姆在那里要做的事。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] your hands up!
举起手来！
Oh yeah. And just to make this more interesting, Chris filmed the whole thing. Carl showed me the footage.
噢，是的。而且为了让这更有趣，克里斯把整个过程都录了下来。卡尔给我看了录像。
Is that Norm?
那是诺姆吗？
That's Norm right there, yes.
那就是诺姆，是的。
Look at this poor kid. He looks like such a goof, on top of it.
看看这个可怜的孩子。他看起来真是个傻瓜，最重要的是。
Yeah. He was. And he's a kid. And his eyes were giant when he had those guns in his face, and he was terrified. Rightfully so. I mean, I would have been terrified if that was me.
是的。他是。而且他是个孩子。当那些枪对着他的脸时，他的眼睛瞪得很大，他吓坏了。理所当然。我的意思是，如果那是我，我也会吓坏的。
Why is his police jersey see-through?
为什么他的警察球衣是透明的？
It's kind of like a mesh pullover thing that you can throw over the side. And we actually made a joke too, about that. That maybe he'd be in his rollerblades on the pier a little bit later.
那是一种你可以穿在身上的网眼套衫之类的东西。我们实际上也开了一个玩笑，关于那个。也许他稍后会在码头滑轮滑。
Yeah. It looks like the kind of thing where he'd come to the door and be like, ma'am, you're under arrest, and then put down the stereo and start stripping.
是的。看起来就像他会来敲门，然后说，夫人，你被捕了，然后放下立体声设备开始脱衣服。
Yes. Exactly.
是的。正是如此。
Chris had two cameras running for better coverage. He wanted to document the day and use the video for his sizzle reel. That's the trailer used to sell shows to TV networks. And it worked. When Chris showed this to Lifetime, part of hooked the network on the PI Moms was the takedown of the Candyman.
克里斯有两台摄像机在运行，以获得更好的报道。他想记录这一天，并将视频用于他的宣传片。那是用来向电视网络推销节目的预告片。而且它奏效了。当克里斯向Lifetime展示这些内容时，吸引该网络关注“妈妈侦探”的一部分就是逮捕“糖果人”。
In truth, Chris was perfect for reality TV. He was a flamboyant character and a master manipulator. Someone who had already been living his life as though he was the star of a show always running in his mind. So it made sense that cable celebrity was the pot of gold at the end of his counterfeit rainbow.
事实上，克里斯非常适合真人秀。他是一个浮夸的角色，是一个操纵大师。一个一直以自己大脑中正在运行的节目明星身份生活的人。所以他在他的假彩虹尽头找到电视名人这个金罐是有道理的。
It was all geared toward getting this TV show and him becoming this Dog the Bounty Hunter-type reality star. I just think he thought somehow that he deserved to be famous.
这一切都是为了得到这个电视节目，让他成为“猎犬多格”那种类型的真人秀明星。我只是觉得他以某种方式认为自己理应出名。
Like any good reality producer, Chris understood the magic of story editing-- how blending some truth with fiction goes a long way.
像任何好的真人秀制作人一样，克里斯理解故事剪辑的魔力——将真实与虚构混合在一起是如何大有帮助的。
Oh yeah. He was always able to legitimize it somehow. And I fell into that in a few things, too. Because there were a lot of times where things we would do, while not quite illegal, kind of had that dirty, immoral kind of feel to them. And even when I would bring that up to Chris, like, should we really be doing this? He would always find a way. Well, you know, because the commander of the Narcotics Task Force is involved, it's kind of like a police operation. So we are allowed to do this, because he's allowing us to do this, and so it's OK.
噢，是的。他总是能以某种方式使其合法化。我也在几件事上陷入了这种情况。因为我们做的很多事情，虽然不完全是非法，但有一种肮脏、不道德的感觉。即使我向克里斯提起这件事，比如，我们真的应该这样做吗？他总能找到办法。好吧，你知道，因为禁毒特遣部队的指挥官参与其中，这就像是一次警察行动。所以我们被允许这样做，因为他在允许我们这样做，所以没问题。
And he always tried to interweave the whole business within the police organizations. Several different police officers were his friends in different jurisdictions. I mean, obviously the commander of the Narcotics Task Force being the highest level. It was always one of those things where we can always do this, because we always have Uncle Norm who can cover for us.
他总是试图将整个业务与警察组织交织在一起。几个不同的警官是他不同管辖区的朋友。我的意思是，显然禁毒特遣部队的指挥官是最高级别的。这总是那种我们可以随时这样做的事情，因为我们总有“诺姆叔叔”可以为我们掩护。
Is that what he called him, Uncle Norm?
他就是这样叫他的吗，诺姆叔叔？
He did.
他确实是。
In addition to Uncle Norm, there were other law enforcement types Chris drew into his schemes. Like the real cops he had stinging unwitting people with DUIs, or the retired FBI guys who gave the PI Moms weapons training at a nearby police range. Chris even convinced Glock Firearms to endorse Butler and Associates, getting a bunch of free pistols and boxes of accessories. Another endorsement was Oakley, which somehow became the firm's official sunglasses, and UFC the official gym.
除了诺姆叔叔，还有其他执法类型的人被克里斯拉进了他的计划中。比如那些真正的警察让他用酒驾刺痛不知情的受害者，或者给妈妈侦探进行武器训练的退休FBI特工。克里斯甚至说服格洛克枪械公司代言巴特勒联合公司，得到了一堆免费手枪和配件箱。另一个代言是奥克利，不知怎么地成为了公司的官方墨镜，而UFC成为了官方健身房。
This was Chris's MO. Creating a seemingly valid world with a veneer of legitimate symbols in a kind of lifestyle forgery. And it was all in the interest of self-promotion.
这就是克里斯的MO（惯用手法）。创造一个表面上有效、具有合法符号外观的世界，一种生活方式造假。而这一切都是为了自我推销。
Coming up. We unpeel one more layer of the onion to reveal underneath all the fakery and pretense and self-promotion, real life crimes. Josh Bearman returns with more in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来。我们要剥开洋葱的又一层，揭示在所有的伪装、假装和自我推销之下，真正的犯罪。乔什·贝尔曼马上回来，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today we're devoting our entire program to one story, The Incredible Case of the PI Moms. If you're just tuning in, this is a detective agency made of good-looking soccer moms created by a guy named Chris Butler, who would not confirm or deny any of this story for us. His attorney did not return repeated phone calls. The PI Moms themselves declined to speak. Josh Bearman picks up the story where we left off before the break.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们将整个节目致力于一个故事，《妈妈侦探的惊人案件》。如果你刚加入收听，这是一个由漂亮的足球妈妈组成的侦探事务所，由一个叫克里斯·巴特勒的人创立，他拒绝为我们确认或否认这个故事。他的律师没有回复多次电话。妈妈侦探们自己也拒绝发表评论。乔什·贝尔曼继续我们休息前中断的故事。
Chris was thinking big. He had visions of a nationwide network of PI Moms franchise offices and detective schools, all with Carl at his side. And Carl was good with that, until he learned that Chris was expanding his operations into full-on crime. It was around the time the PI Moms started shooting their reality show with Lifetime.
克里斯考虑得很长远。他设想着一个全国范围的“妈妈侦探”特许经营办公室和侦探学校网络，身边都是卡尔。卡尔对此没问题，直到他得知克里斯正在将他的行动扩展到全面的犯罪。就在“妈妈侦探”开始与Lifetime拍摄真人秀的时候。
Well, at one point during the early filming of the show, Chris Butler brought me into the warehouse, and brought me over to a case, and basically said to me, you live in San Francisco. You probably know people that smoke marijuana. I'm like, I think everybody I know smokes marijuana in San Francisco. It's kind of-- I started laughing. He goes, well, would you know people who would be interested in buying it? I'm like, well, I know people that do smoke marijuana. I don't know who would buy or who doesn't. So he brings me over to this case, he opens it up, and I think there was nine pounds of marijuana wrapped in these plastic bags.
好吧，在节目拍摄初期的一次，克里斯·巴特勒把我带到仓库，带我到一个箱子旁边，基本上对我说，你住在旧金山。你可能认识抽大麻的人。我当时想，我想我认识的每个人都在旧金山抽大麻。这有点——我开始笑了。他说，好吧，你认识会对买它感兴趣的人吗？我心想，好吧，我知道有人抽大麻。我不知道谁会买，谁不会。所以他把我带到那个箱子旁边，打开它，我想里面有九磅重的大麻，裹在这些塑料袋里。
Carl was taken aback. But even more shocking was his second thought.
卡尔大吃一惊。但更令他震惊的是他的第二个想法。
When he opened this case, it was one of those revelations where I immediately knew where they came from. Which he immediately confirmed by saying, well, I'm not going to say his name, but you know where this probably comes from. And-- he wanted to refer to him as uncle. And that's where he started-- not even Uncle Norm. Just Uncle.
当他打开这个箱子时，这是那种让我立刻知道它们从哪来的启示之一。他立即确认说，好吧，我不会说他的名字，但你知道这可能从哪来。而且——他想称他为叔叔。这就是他开始的地方——甚至不是诺姆叔叔。只是叔叔。
It's worth remembering here that Uncle Norm, now cleverly code named Uncle, was the top drug cop in the county. The guy you'd see on TV taking credit when there was a big drug bust where they'd show a table piled high with contraband. And now, Carl realized, Norm was stealing those same drugs from the evidence locker to recirculate them via Chris, who was extending a hand with a tightly wrapped pound to Carl.
值得记住的是，诺姆叔叔，现在被巧妙地代号为“叔叔”，是该县的最高禁毒警察。你在电视上看到的那个人，当有大案抓捕时，他会炫耀堆满违禁品的桌子。现在，卡尔意识到，诺姆从证据柜里偷走了同样的毒品，通过克里斯重新分发，而克里斯正在把紧紧裹着的一磅大麻递给卡尔。
And it was one of those points in your life where you kind of feel almost trapped. And I remember thinking that I want to say no. I've never sold drugs in my life. I'm not a drug dealer.
这是你生命中那种让你觉得几乎被困住的点之一。我记得我当时在想，我想说不。我这辈子从没卖过毒品。我不是毒贩。
But at that point, I'm also kind of like, this is a situation where I'm already wrapped up in Chris Butler's business. I know so much stuff about Chris Butler. If I say no and give this back to him, it's going to be a personal insult to Chris Butler, first of all. And it's going to be one of those things where I'm kind of scared if I say no.
但在那个时候，我也心想，这是一个我已经卷入克里斯·巴特勒业务的情况。我知道关于克里斯·巴特勒的太多事情。如果我拒绝并把它还给他，这首先是对克里斯·巴特勒的个人侮辱。而且如果我拒绝，我有点害怕，这会是那种事情。
And he knows you're not on board?
他知道你没参与？
I know what he's capable of. I've seen what he's capable of. I mean, to the point where he was going to plant drugs on people in the past for clients. And I've watched him set so many people up. I know Chris Butler will set me up somehow, to have some sort of leverage over me, so I don't give up his dirty secrets.
我知道他能做什么。我见过他能做什么。我的意思是，到他过去为了客户而向人们栽赃毒品的程度。我看过他陷害了那么多人。我知道克里斯·巴特勒会以某种方式陷害我，以掌握关于我的一些筹码，这样我就不会泄露他的肮脏秘密。
Carl takes a deep breath, says he'll try a cousin in San Jose, and takes the drugs home. There he tells his wife, who says he has to go to the police. But Carl has already thought about that.
卡尔深吸了一口气，说他会去圣何塞找一个表亲，然后把毒品带回家。在那里他告诉了他的妻子，妻子说他必须报警。但卡尔已经考虑过这一点了。
I'm like, who I go to? This came from the Narcotics Task Force commander. She's like, what are you going to do? Are you going to sell it? I'm like, no, I'm not going to sell it!
心想，我找谁？这来自禁毒特遣部队的指挥官。她说，你打算怎么办？你打算卖掉它吗？心想，不，我不打算卖掉它！
Well, you're really stuck here. Because you don't know-- now you realize that there are dirty cops at a very high level. And Butler knows people everywhere.
好吧，你真的被困在这里了。因为你不知道——现在你意识到有高层级的脏警察。巴特勒到处都认识人。
Yes. So we sit and we discuss it for a while, and she's like, well, who do you go to? Do you just walk into the Concord Police Department and say hey, by the way, the PI down the street is selling drugs? And I'm like, Chris Butler knows half the guys in the Concord Police Department. Who knows if they're involved. I have no idea the level that this goes to. I think about going to the District Attorney's office, but I know that Norm knows all those people. He's testified, I'm sure, numerous times. I have no idea who's tainted by this. Honestly, I'm stuck. I don't know where to go with it.
是的。所以我们坐下来讨论了一会儿，她说，好吧，你找谁？你是直接走进康科德警察局，说嘿，顺便问一下，街上的私家侦探在卖毒品？心想，克里斯·巴特勒认识康科德警察局的一半人。谁知道他们是否参与其中。我根本不知道这涉及的程度。我考虑过找地区检察官办公室，但我知道诺姆认识所有那些人。我相信他已经作证过无数次。我根本不知道谁被这件事玷污了。老实说，我被困住了。我不知道该拿它怎么办。
Carl stalls for weeks. He's telling Chris that they have to wait for the buyer, making things up. Chris puts on the pressure, saying that Norm is getting nervous and they want the money now.
卡尔拖延了几个星期。他告诉克里斯他们必须等买家，编造事情。克里斯施加压力，说诺姆正变得紧张，他们现在想要钱。
So my wife and I go to the ATM that night and take out our own money.
所以那天晚上我和我妻子去了自动取款机，取出了我们自己的钱。
Carl and his wife take out $1600.
卡尔和他的妻子取出了1600美元。
And I pay Chris Butler for the pound of weed, and just tell him that this money came from our buyer down in San Jose. Which makes him very happy.
我付钱给克里斯·巴特勒买那一磅大麻，只是告诉他这笔钱来自我们在圣何塞的买家。这让他很高兴。
So you bought it.
所以你买了它。
Yeah. I ended up being the buyer of the pound of weed. Just to kind of satisfy Chris, and just so I can kind of buy a little more time until we can figure out who to go to.
是的。我最终成了那一磅大麻的买家。只是为了满足克里斯，也为了让我能多争取一点时间，直到我们能弄清楚该找谁。
At that point, we go back to the office. Since I did such a good job, here's another pound of weed. So I have another pound of weed I take my house, and I put it with the original pound in my closet. And my wife's like, what-- I can't afford to buy another pound of weed!
那时候，我们回到办公室。既然我干得这么好，这是另外一磅大麻。所以我又得到了一磅大麻，我把它带回家，和最初那一磅放在一起在壁橱里。我妻子说，什么——我负担不起买另外一磅大麻！
Carl was only getting himself in deeper. Since he couldn't go to the cops, Carl thought about going to the local paper, but he worried that a reporter on the police desk might ask the wrong cop the wrong question, and tip off Norm and Chris anyhow. So with limited options, Carl took the best one he saw-- the lifestyle reporter from the local glossy magazine.
卡尔只会让自己陷得更深。因为他不能找警察，卡尔考虑找当地报纸，但他担心警察口的记者可能会问错警察错的问题，总之会提醒诺姆和克里斯。所以，选项有限，卡尔采取了他能看到最好的一个——来自当地亮面杂志的生活方式记者。
That's how Carl became Rutherford, reaching out to Pete and revealing that the stakeout was fake. It was a way for Carl to test the waters with Pete, to see what he'd believe. And when Pete started snooping around, it actually put Carl in a strange bind, because Chris got spooked and asked Carl, his trusted lieutenant, to do some damage control. Again, here's Carl.
这就是卡尔如何成为“卢瑟福”，联系上皮特并透露监视行动是伪造的。这是卡尔测试皮特信任度的一种方式，看看他会相信什么。当皮特开始到处打听时，这实际上让卡尔陷入了一个奇怪的困境，因为克里斯被吓坏了，要求卡尔，他信任的副手，做一些危机控制。再次介绍一下，这是卡尔。
Chris decides, well, you've got to make sure. Make sure you talk to Pete. Give him a call and convince him that everything was real. Like, being the director of operations and stuff.
克里斯决定，好吧，你必须确保。确保你和皮特谈谈。给他打个电话，让他相信一切都是真的。比如，做行动总监什么的。
So now I call Pete up on the phone-- as Carl Marino, obviously-- and I have an hour, hour and 20 minute talk with Pete, convincing him how everything was completely true. Going through every step of the way, and how, well, even though this might have seemed kind of funny, no, that was really real. Because it really would've-- and I'm completely honest on that part of it, because those are all real things that could have happened. And at one point, I just want to say, Pete, I'm Ronald Rutherford, all right?
所以现在我给皮特打了个电话——显然是以卡尔·马里诺的身份——我和皮特谈了一个小时，一个小时20分钟，让他相信一切都是完全真实的。一步步过一遍，而且，即使这看起来有点可笑，不，那是真的。因为它确实会——我在那部分完全诚实，因为那些都是可能发生的真实事情。有一次，我只是想说，皮特，我是罗纳德·卢瑟福，好吗？
So you're talking to him as Carl to convince him that it's true, while Rutherford is simultaneously, via email, trying to convince them that it's fake?
所以你是以卡尔的身份和他交谈，让他相信它是真的，同时“卢瑟福”又通过电子邮件试图让他们相信它是假的？
Yes.
是的。
Right. But then also, as Carl, you do want him to not think that it's Carl, because you want Rutherford to remain anonymous. So you're actually kind of glad to be on the phone with him as Carl, trying to convince him that it's real.
对。但也作为卡尔，你确实希望他不要认为那是卡尔，因为你希望“卢瑟福”保持匿名。所以你实际上有点高兴以卡尔的身份和他通电话，试图让他相信它是真的。
Yes.
是的。
So it took a while, but finally Carl trusted Pete enough to let him in on the much bigger, more serious scandal. Here's Pete.
所以花了一段时间，但最终卡尔足够信任皮特，让他参与到了更大、更严重的丑闻中。这是皮特。
I get this email from Rutherford that says, "I'm hesitant to tell you this. Mr. Butler is involved in some serious criminal activity right now. Butler is very well-connected in the police community and with the Narcotics Task Force I am not sure who to contact about this, and I assure you that it is serious."
我收到“卢瑟福”发来的一封电子邮件，上面写着，“我犹豫要不要告诉你这个。巴特勒先生现在涉及一些严重的犯罪活动。巴特勒在警察社区和禁毒特遣部队中关系非常好。我不确定该联系谁，但我向你保证，这很严重。”
And this started to get at this nagging question I had, which is why is Rutherford telling me all this information? It seemed like it was excessively helpful, as far as just protecting Diablo magazine and myself from writing a fake ride-along story for Chris Butler. But in my mind, I wondered, is there something that Rutherford needs to tell, and that's what it was?
这开始触及我心中的一个挥之不去的问题，就是为什么“卢瑟福”要告诉我所有这些信息？似乎这在保护《迪亚布罗》杂志和我不为克里斯·巴特勒写一篇虚假的行动故事方面帮助太大了。但在我心中，我心想，是否有“卢瑟福”需要讲述的事情，这就是它了？
So I wrote back and asked, what is this criminal activity? And Rutherford wrote back, "Butler is selling large amounts of marijuana along with other drugs, prescription Xanax and steroids, that have been confiscated by the Contra Costa County Task Force."
所以我回信问，这是什么犯罪活动？“卢瑟福”回信说，“巴特勒正在销售大量的大麻以及其他毒品，处方药赞安诺和类固醇，这些都是被康特拉科斯塔县特遣部队没收的。”
Again, here's Carl.
再次介绍一下，这是卡尔。
So I don't hear back for a little bit. Of course, now I'm just frantic. Checking my email every ten seconds. Because it's like, where's this going to go? Does he tell the wrong person? I have no idea what's going on at this point.
所以我等了一会儿没有回音。当然，现在我只是发疯了。每十秒钟检查一次电子邮件。因为就像是，这会走向哪里？他告诉错人了？此时我根本不知道发生了什么。
At Diablo magazine, Pete Crooks covers culture and entertainment. He writes a column called Pete's Popcorn Picks. Crime is not his beat.
在《迪亚布罗》杂志，皮特·克鲁克斯负责文化和娱乐。他写一个叫“皮特爆米花精选”的专栏。犯罪不是他的报道领域。
But it turned out that Carl had chosen the right confidant. Pete had a good police contact, a friend who put him in touch with the right people in law enforcement, and a full-on investigation started up. The case got kicked up the chain of command on account of the dirty cops.
但事实证明，卡尔选择了正确的知己。皮特有一个很好的警察联系人，一个朋友让他联系上了执法部门的正确人选，并开始了一场全面的调查。由于脏警察的缘故，案件被移交到了更高的指挥链。
And soon enough, Carl became an undercover informant. He wore a wire, sometimes two, recording not just sound but video. For weeks, he led a double life. Now he was staging fake drug deals, handing over cash for Chris's drugs, supposedly to resell in San Jose, while state Department of Justice investigators were stationed in the nearby van, or the bushes, or other tactical locations, watching it all.
很快，卡尔成了卧底线人。他带着窃听器，有时是两个，记录的不仅是声音，还有视频。几周来，他过着双重生活。现在他正在策划虚假的毒品交易，支付现金买克里斯的毒品，推测是在圣何塞转售，而州司法部调查员驻扎在附近的货车里，或灌木丛中，或其他战术位置，看着这一切。
If that's not complicated enough, in the midst of all this, it's easy to forget that the reality show was now in full production. There were two sets of cameras-- one for the DOJ and one for Lifetime-- and at times, they were filming the same people and places. There were so many overlapping storylines it was hard sometimes for Carl to keep it straight.
如果这还不够复杂，在这期间，很容易忘记真人秀现在处于全面制作中。有两套摄像机——一套给司法部，一套给Lifetime——有时，他们拍摄的是同样的人和地方。情节重叠太多，有时卡尔很难理清思路。
Yes. It was very surreal. At one point, we would film on the one side, where the conference room was, in my office in the front, and Chris's office in the back. And that's where most of the filming took place. And the Video Village setup was in the storage part, which was the other half, where Chris kept all of his equipment. A few of the vehicles were there. And of course, the locked black case that had-- I think at this point it has 12 pounds of marijuana in it-- that the crew members are using as a chair to sit on.
是的。这非常超现实。有一次，我们在那边拍摄，会议室在那里，前面的办公室在我的办公室，后面的在克里斯的办公室。那是大部分拍摄发生的地方。而“视频村”设置在仓库部分，那是另一半，克里斯保存了他所有的设备。一些车辆在那里。当然，还有锁着的黑色箱子——我想此时里面有12磅重的大麻——机组成员正把它当作椅子坐着。
And I remember walking in there and it's like, wow. How surreal is this? Here's this production crew, filming this reality show in the other room, sitting on 12 pounds of marijuana they have no idea is locked in that case right now. That I'm doing undercover operations for the Department of Justice to sting Chris Butler. I'll be buying those 12 pounds, eventually.
我记得走进去，心想，哇。这太超现实了。这是一个制作组，在另一个房间拍真人秀，坐在他们不知道锁在那个箱子里的12磅大麻上。而我正在为司法部进行卧底行动，诱捕克里斯·巴特勒。我最终会买下那12磅。
Meanwhile, Chris's main worry was that he was being edged out of the reality show. It turns out that some dude named Chris was simply not as exciting as sexy moms on the case. There was constant petty jealousy and small-time Machiavellian hijinks as everyone jockeyed for attention from the producers. When Chris realized he was not the star, he panicked.
与此同时，克里斯的主要担心是他正被挤出真人秀。事实证明，某个叫克里斯的人根本没有案例中的性感妈妈那么刺激。由于每个人都在争取制作人的注意力，经常出现琐碎的嫉妒和轻微的马基雅维利式的恶作剧。当克里斯意识到他不是明星时，他惊慌失措。
But the show itself was a disaster anyhow. Cases were falling apart, and everyone-- the Moms, Chris, Carl, and the producers-- blamed each other. Part of the problem was that Chris had sold the show based on fake cases, and now there weren't enough real clients for the PI Moms to help.
但节目本身无论如何都是一场灾难。案例纷纷分崩离析，每个人——妈妈们、克里斯、卡尔和制作人们——都互相指责。问题的一部分是克里斯是基于虚假案例推销节目的，现在没有足够的真实客户让妈妈侦探去帮助。
That may be where the drug deals came in. One person close to Chris says that he was desperate for money to stage more fake cases for Lifetime and rescue the show. But it was too late. I've talked to people who worked on the program, and I can't use their names, but they said the whole thing was an insane mess. And in early February, Lifetime pulled the plug. The show was over.
这可能就是毒品交易发挥作用的地方。一个接近克里斯的人说，他渴望钱来为Lifetime策划更多虚假案件并拯救节目。但太晚了。我和那些在节目中工作过的人谈过，我不能用他们的名字，但他们说整个节目是一团乱麻。二月初，Lifetime拔掉了插头。节目结束了。
All this time, the drug deals started to feel more dangerous for Carl. Chris was about to get his hands on some methamphetamine. Carl was getting increasingly paranoid. At one point, Carl says, Chris even tried to set him up, sending an unmarked police car to sit in the alley behind his house before one of the drug buys. The next day, in an I-know-that-you-know-that-I-know conversation, Carl says that Chris basically admitted he had fired a warning shot. But Carl still didn't know how much Chris knew.
一直以来，毒品交易对卡尔来说开始感觉更危险。克里斯即将得到一些甲基苯丙胺。卡尔变得越来越偏执。卡尔说，有一次，克里斯甚至试图陷害他，在其中一次毒品购买前，派了一辆没标记的警车停在他家后面的小巷里。第二天，在一次“我知道你知道我知道”的对话中，卡尔说克里斯基本上承认他打了一记警示枪。但卡尔仍然不知道克里斯知道多少。
You know, I'm waiting for the other shoe to drop with Chris. If all of a sudden he finds out, I'm going to find myself going on a long ride into the woods somewhere. I've seen him set so many people up. And you'll never see it coming until it's already there.
你知道，我等着克里斯的另一只靴子掉下来。如果他突然发现，我就会发现自己要被带去树林里进行漫长的兜风。我见过他陷害了那么多人。你永远不会看到它到来，直到它已经在那儿了。
By now, Carl had collected plenty of video of Chris selling drugs. But the DOJ only had Chris on camera, and nothing on Norm.
到现在为止，卡尔收集了大量克里斯卖毒品的视频。但司法部只有克里斯在镜头上，对诺姆一无所获。
Then one day, Carl gets a sudden message from DOJ investigators. They've been watching Chris, and Chris is on his way over to sell Carl the meth. But he's not alone. Norm is with him. This was a surprise. Norm never showed up on these deals, and the unexpected change was suspicious.
然后有一天，卡尔收到司法部调查员的突然信息。他们一直在监视克里斯，克里斯正在去向卡尔卖冰毒的路上。但他不是一个人。诺姆和他在一起。这是一个惊喜。诺姆从未出现在这些交易中，这种意想不到的改变令人怀疑。
So now at this point, I'm terrified. Why is Norm coming back to the office? And at this point, I think the Department of Justice is terrified also. Why is Norm coming back to the office? I get a frantic text message. "They're coming back. Hide the devices."
所以现在我吓坏了。诺姆为什么要回办公室？此时，我认为司法部也吓坏了。诺姆为什么要回办公室？我收到一条疯狂的短信。“他们要回来了。藏起设备。”
This is from the DOJ people?
这是司法部的人发来的？
Yes. So now I'm thinking, these guys are coming back to kill me right now. They have found out somehow. And the first thing Norm would do, I know, when he comes in this room, he's going to pat search me, and he's going to find my devices.
是的。所以现在我想，这些人现在要回来杀我了。他们以某种方式发现了。而我所知道的，当诺姆进来这个房间时，他要做的第一件事就是拍打搜查我，他会发现我的设备。
So I'm frantically hiding them, trying to think of what's going to happen now. And I'm the only one in the office. I don't have a gun. Both of them do have guns, and they wear their guns all the time.
所以我疯狂地藏起它们，试图思考现在会发生什么。我是办公室里唯一的人。我没有枪。他们两个确实有枪，而且他们一直戴着枪。
And so by hiding the devices, also, does that mean now the investigators can't hear you?  They don't know what's going on in there?
所以隐藏设备，这也意味着现在调查员听不到你的声音了吗？他们不知道那里发生了什么？
No, no. So yeah. At this point, I think there's a chance I might die in this office.
不，不。所以是的。在这一点上，我想我可能会死在这个办公室里。
Carl later learned that the DOJ had put snipers in position, just in case. But Norm, it turned out, was not there to kill Carl, and neither was Chris. It was all a coincidence. Norm had come with Chris that night so they could install a hidden camera in a coffee maker. Why would they need that? Carl didn't ask. He was just glad they weren't that interested in him.
卡尔后来得知司法部已经部署了狙击手，以防万一。但诺姆，事实证明，并不是去杀卡尔，克里斯也不是。这一切都是巧合。诺姆那天晚上和克里斯一起过来，是为了在咖啡机里安装一个隐藏摄像头。他们为什么需要那个？卡尔没问。他只是庆幸他们对他没那么感兴趣。
One of the biggest reliefs of my life, that moment when I realized, OK. I'm going to make it out of here today.
我一生中最大的解脱之一，那一刻我意识到，好的。我今天能从这里活着走出去。
So they get done talking about the coffeepot, and they're like, OK, you've got the money, right? Let's do this. So I'm like, OK, sure. And at this point, I'm like, screw it. I'm going to film this, too. Because I've had enough of this. I honestly don't want to do any more drug deals. I'm going to get them whatever they need.
所以他们谈完咖啡壶，就像，好的，你有钱了，对吧？让我们做吧。所以我想，好的，当然。在这一点上，我想，去他的。我也要拍下这个。因为我受够了。老实说，我不想再做任何毒品交易了。我会给他们任何他们需要的。
So Carl went into the other room, retrieved one of his hidden video cameras, and got into position as Chris and Norm weighed out a pound of meth. Carl taped them as they counted out $5000 in cash. Chris and Norm never suspected a thing. Mostly they joked about how the money wasn't in small bills.
所以卡尔走进另一个房间，取回了他的一台隐藏摄像机，并在克里斯和诺姆称出一磅冰毒时就位。卡尔在他们清点5000美元现金时录下了他们。克里斯和诺姆什么都没怀疑。大多数时候，他们开玩笑说钱不是小面额的。
It was Carl's last performance as a low-level distributor. That night, after it was all over, one of the DOJ cops even complimented him on his camera work. He told Carl it was the best footage they'd ever seen.
那是卡尔作为低级经销商的最后一场表演。那天晚上，这一切结束后，一名司法部警察甚至称赞了他的摄像技术。他告诉卡尔这是他们见过的最好的镜头。
Tonight the law enforcement community is stunned. A narcotics cop and a private investigator both accused of selling drugs. Commander Norman Wielsch and his friend Christopher Butler were booked into the Contra Costa County Jail in Martinez this morning.
今晚执法界感到震惊。一名缉毒警察和一名私家侦探都被指控销售毒品。诺曼·威尔施指挥官和他的朋友克里斯托弗·巴特勒今天早上被关进了马丁内斯的康特拉科斯塔县监狱。
Chris and Norm were both arrested the next day. Between them, they were charged with 17 felony counts. They're both facing life in prison. The indictment describes an assortment of other alleged crimes we haven't even heard about yet. Like the happy ending massage parlor Chris and Norm are accused of running called My Divine Skin; and supposedly shaking down prostitutes they'd find on Craigslist.
克里斯和诺姆第二天都被捕了。他们两人共被控17项重罪。他们两人都面临终身监禁。起诉书描述了我们甚至还未听过的其他各种涉嫌犯罪。比如克里斯和诺姆被指控经营的叫“我神圣的皮肤”的快乐结局按摩院；以及涉嫌敲诈他们在Craiglist上找到的妓女。
Chris was arrested outside the UFC gym, where he immediately clammed up and asked for a lawyer. Norm, on the other hand-- well, here's Norm.
克里斯在UFC健身房外被捕，他立即闭口不谈并要求找律师。另一方面，诺姆——这是诺姆。
I'm taking full responsibility of what I did. I'm not-- again, I did wrong, and I expect to pay for it. I know I'm going to have to go to jail and I've made peace with that.
我对我所做的事承担全部责任。我不是——再说一次，我做错了，我期望为此付出代价。我知道我将不得不进监狱，我已经对此感到平静了。
When Norm was arrested, he started crying and confessed right away. Since then, he's been cooperating with investigators. And yes, Norm took responsibility for what he did. But during an interview in his lawyer's office with his wife by his side, he also laid out what he calls the mitigating factors that allowed Chris Butler to influence, and according to them, take advantage of Norm.
当诺姆被捕时，他开始哭泣并立即认罪。从那以后，他一直在配合调查员。是的，诺姆对他所做的事承担了责任。但在他律师办公室、妻子陪伴下的采访中，他也列出了他称之为“减轻因素”的内容，这使得克里斯·巴特勒能够影响，并据他们所说，利用了诺姆。
Because of my ailments, let's say, I felt inside-- because I was always a big strong guy, you know, a big strong cop. All of a sudden I get sick, and bam, there goes my health. So I'm no longer that big strong-- even though I'm putting up a good fake for people, I'm feeling like a shell of a man.
因为我的疾病，咱们说吧，我心里感觉——因为我曾经是个高大强壮的家伙，你知道，一个高大强壮的警察。突然之间我病倒了，砰，我的健康没了。所以我不再是那个高大强壮的——尽管我给人们假装很好，我觉得自己像个空壳人。
Also, his mother had died. His daughter was sick. He was depressed and suffering from a disease that slowly deformed his hands and feet. I couldn't really picture why that would matter, but they pressed it.
此外，他的母亲去世了。他的女儿病了。他感到抑郁，患有一种缓慢导致手脚畸形的疾病。我真的想象不出为什么这会有关系，但他们坚持这么说。
Show them your feet. Show them your foot. If you were to look at his foot-- I want you see it--
给他们看看你的脚。给他们看看你的脚。如果你要看他的脚——我希望你看看——
Norm didn't show me, but then the lawyer flashed me a photo of Norm's foot on a cell phone.
诺姆没给我看，但随后律师在手机上向我展示了一张诺姆脚的照片。
Over 18 surgeries in the last ten years.
过去十年里做了18次以上的手术。
The feet were pretty gnarly. I should mention, Norm really did sound like a guy who realized he had made a huge mistake and was reconsidering his whole life. Trying to understand how he could be so vulnerable to temptation. After all, the money was trivial. Turns out it was only around $12,000. And Norm had a lot to lose-- more than anyone else, probably. But he says it was Chris. He was just so convincing.
脚相当扭曲。我应该提到，诺姆听起来确实像一个意识到自己犯了大错并正在重新审视自己整个人生的人。试图理解他怎么会如此容易受到诱惑。毕竟，钱是微不足道的。事实证明只有大约12000美元。而诺姆失去的很多——大概比任何人都多。但他说是克里斯。他太有说服力了。
Whoever's talked to Chris knows that he has the gift of gab. He could talk you into buying anything. I mean, I'm not blaming him. But he had his way of coercing a little bit more, you know? Where if I would say, hey, that's a stupid idea, all of a sudden the golden tongue would come out, and then all of a sudden I'd be driving home, thinking, oh, that's not a bad idea.
任何和克里斯谈过的人都知道他有“三寸不烂之舌”。他能说服你买任何东西。我的意思是，我不是在责怪他。但他有他那种稍微强迫人的方式，你知道吗？如果我说，嘿，那是个愚蠢的主意，突然间金舌头就出来了，然后突然间我就开车回家，心想，哦，那不是个坏主意。
While Norm blames Chris, Chris blames Norm. Chris's lawyer has pointed out that Norm was the guy with the badge. Norm was the one who signed the drugs out of the evidence locker. The lawyer says Norm was in charge. It was all his idea.
当诺姆责怪克里斯时，克里斯责怪诺姆。克里斯的律师指出，诺姆是那个戴着警徽的人。诺姆是那个从证据柜里签出毒品的人。律师说诺姆在负责。这一切都是他的主意。
Norm says no. Chris was the Svengali, the showman.
诺姆说不。克里斯是那个邪恶大师，表演者。
He was always buying lunch. He always insisted on buying lunch. And he'd pull out his credit card, and then he would bring some of girls there, and he would make sure that they were dressed all pretty and stuff.
他总是请客吃饭。他总是坚持请客吃饭。他会拿出信用卡，然后他会带一些女孩去那里，他会确保她们穿得很漂亮什么的。
There's a little theater to it.
这有点戏剧性。
There's a little theater to it, exactly. And then he would come in his black Mercedes. And you're impressed.  You sit and go wow, you know? But anyway, we--
这有点戏剧性，正是如此。然后他会开着他的黑色奔驰进来。你印象深刻。你坐下来心想哇，你知道吗？但是无论如何，我们——
Even now, in his lawyer's conference room, you could hear in Norm's voice that he still feels it little bit. That Chris had some kind of hold on him, as he did on so many other people. It's obvious when you see Chris in action.
即使现在，在他律师的会议室里，你也能在诺姆的声音中听到他仍然感觉到了一点点。克里斯对他有某种控制力，就像他对他周围那么多人一样。当你看到克里斯行动时，这就很明显了。
Lifetime won't release the PI Moms footage, so all I've seen is that video of the Candyman bust, the one I watched with Carl Marino. My favorite moment is not the bust itself, but when Chris is back in his office, presiding over his crew-- Norm, Carl, the two pretty girl decoys, and various other investigators. The bust has gone off without a hitch. Someone even thought to bring champagne. And Chris is recounting, in vivid detail, the glorious crescendo of his operation.
Lifetime不会发布“妈妈侦探”的镜头，所以我只看了那个逮捕“糖果人”的视频，就是我和卡尔·马里诺一起看的那一段。我最喜欢的时刻不是逮捕本身，而是当克里斯回到办公室，主持他的船员——诺姆、卡尔、两个漂亮的女孩诱饵，以及其他各种调查员。逮捕非常顺利。甚至有人想到带香槟。克里斯正在生动地叙述他行动的高潮。
But it means you're not going to jail right now, so sit down.
但这意味着你现在不会去坐牢，所以坐下。
They're are hanging on Chris, reveling in his encore performance of the special scenes his team couldn't see, where he and Norm played a little good cop-bad cop with the Candyman.
他们粘着克里斯，陶醉于他对他团队没看到的特别场景的安可表演，在那里他和诺姆跟“糖果人”玩了一点点好警察-坏警察。
I said, I worked a month on his case, and you're just going to let him go? He's going, Calm down, just do what you're told. So go outside and chill out. And so  anyway, I come back around the corner and I'm just-- you know what? I turn to him, I said, you know what? I've got seven years of following this. So don't even think you can get away with it.
我说，我在他的案件上工作了一个月，你就打算让他走？他说，冷静点，做你被告知的事。所以去外面放松一下。无论如何，我绕过角落回来，我只是——你知道吗？我转向他说，你知道吗？我已经跟踪这个七年了。所以别以为你能逃脱。
Everyone in that room broke the law, but they were celebrating it like a civic duty. That's how Chris allowed them to see it. Because if Chris had a genius for fantasy, it was that he understood that everyone had their own particular fantasy, and he could spot it and harness it, and weave it together with the rest of the people in his web.
那个房间里的每个人都触犯了法律，但他们庆祝它就像庆祝一项公民义务。这就是克里斯让他们看的方式。因为如果克里斯有幻想的天赋，那就是他理解每个人都有他们自己特定的幻想，他可以发现它并利用它，并把它与他网中其他人交织在一起。
The Moms wanted to be on TV. Norm wanted to feel powerful again. The media wanted a good story. The Candyman got a little fantasy date. Even Carl told me that before he first blew the whistle on Chris, he hesitated. Not just because he was scared, but because he, too was taken by Chris's grand vision.
妈妈们想上电视。诺姆想再次感到强大。媒体想要一个好故事。糖果人得到了一个小的幻想约会。甚至卡尔也告诉我，在他第一次揭发克里斯之前，他犹豫了。不仅是因为他害怕，还因为他也被克里斯宏大的愿景所吸引。
It's like something Chris said the last time Pete saw him before he was arrested. Chris was being filmed for the reality show. He was doing one of those confessional interviews, talking to the producer. "The thing about people," Chris said to the camera, "is that they want to believe you. You don't have to give them much, and they'll come right along."
这就像皮特在被捕前最后一次见他时克里斯说的话。克里斯正在为真人秀拍摄。他正在做那些忏悔式采访之一，与制作人交谈。“关于人的一点是，”克里斯对摄像机说，“他们想相信你。你不需要给他们太多，他们就会跟着你来。”
Josh Bearman in Los Angeles.
乔什·贝尔曼，在洛杉矶。
[MUSIC - "THE JIG IS UP" BY GENERAL RUDIE]
[音乐 - “骗局败露”，General Rudie]
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and Ben Calhoun with Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Nikki Meek. Seth Lind is our production manager. Brian Judd is filling in as office manager.
好吧，我们的节目今天由萨拉·凯尼格和本·卡尔霍恩制作，乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。尼基·米克提供制作帮助。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理。布莱恩·贾德暂时担任办公室经理。
At our website, you can get our free weekly podcasts, listen to our programs for free online, get our apps for iPhone, iPad, or Android, which are, by the way, fantastic-- especially that iPad one-- all at thisamericanlife.org.
在我们的网站上，你可以获取我们免费的每周播客，在线免费收听我们的节目，获取我们适用于iPhone、iPad或Android的应用程序，顺便说一下，它们非常棒——尤其是iPad的那一个——都在thisamericanlife.org。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. When he gets low on electrolytes, he is not shy about fixing that problem. No, no, no. He will walk up to any sweaty person, man or woman, any age, race, or creed, and tell them--
WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督，由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。当他电解质不足时，他不羞于解决这个问题。不，不，不。他会走向任何出汗的人，男人或女人，任何年龄、种族或信仰，并告诉他们——
I'd like to lick that sweat off of you.
我想舔掉你身上的汗水。
Sweat, salt, electrolytes, anybody?
汗水、盐分、电解质，有人需要吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》的更多故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。